tis the season to make sure your holiday
etiquette is intact okay Sheila Keys is
here with some expert tips and reminders
welcome back thank you so much it's
lovely to see you again you too Sheila
now I just finally found a couple
co-worker gifts last night I know I'm a
last minute that's good but so let's
let's start with that you know what's
the holiday etiquette that we should
consider when you know gifting our
co-workers and our bosses do we have to
oh gosh do you have to it's the best of
friends you know I always say it depends
if it's a small office environment but
everybody's toasty and cozy and you all
know one another and you know what each
other like so yes you can do but yeah
you'll get yours later but um if it's
like you know a bigger office and who
don't want to be seen you know to be
handing your boss something because of
what other co-workers might think then
do it very discreetly yeah yeah it can
do you know we don't want any issues
going back in New Years right right
exactly and you work closely with these
people so of course now moving out of
the workplace into the home or the so
social space people are having holiday
parties yes what's the approach there
because that can get oh gosh that can
get messy I actually read a lovely post
Emily post uh blog last week and she was
talking about holiday parties being like
an artist doing a painting okay where
you've got all the paints and you want
to make sure they all gel together so
therefore your guests to your home make
sure they all sort of gel together you
know don't invite Aunt Mary thinking and
knowing that she's going to cause a
little Ruckus at the end of it yeah
exactly so be strategic yeah yeah plan
your party because you want to have fun
as well and you don't want that anxiety
of dealing with oh my goodness should I
have done this should I have not
absolutely and what about those
difficult family members or friends that
you might have to invite well I think
you just grit your teeth at that point
you know because it's the holidays and
we want to keep everybody happy
absolutely and if you are hosting the
party really quick you know if you have
a vegan or vegetarian food restrictions
always keep a piece of salmon or
something in your freezer can be
defrosted really quickly and therefore
you know you'll have people coming in
and they won't feel left out and you
know first and foremost just enjoy
yourself yeah it's it's that time don't
stress absolutely yeah one of your best
advice pieces of advice here is make
sure your guests are having fun but yeah
sure you're having you have to have fun
otherwise what's the point absolutely
yeah thank you Sheila Merry Christmas